so we are here
to uh give a documentary out to give an
oscar out for best documentary
now the beauty of documentaries because
they they make you when you watch one
you feel smart
like you watch them like you know like
you read a book or something
but all you really did was get high and
watch netflix
so here we go
here we go
the documentaries the nominees are let's
just go to nominees
ascension jessica kingdon kara simon
kennedy and nathan truesdale
attica stanley nelson and tracy a curry
flea jonas hoare rasmussen monica
hellstrom cena bureau sirensen and
charlotte de la gorneri
summer of soul when the revolution could
not be televised amir questlove thompson
joseph patel robert fibulant and david
dinnerston riding with fire rentu thomas
and sue smith gosh
thank god
and the winner is
i hope this is right
summer of seoul
when the revolution could not be
televised
amir
thompson
and four white guys
this is the first oscar and nomination
for amir questlove thompson joseph patel
robert kivalen and david dinnerstein
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
um
thank you
hey real quick real quick um
first i will i would like to acknowledge
attica ascension and flee and riding
with flyer for their powerful work
um
it's not lost on me
that
the story the harlem cultural festival
should have been
something that my beautiful mother
my dad
should have
taken me to when i was five years old
and
i'm just this is such a stunning moment
for me right now
um but this is not about me this is
about
marginalized people
in harlem
that
needed to heal from pain and just know
that in 2022
you know this is not just a 1969 story
about marginalized people in harlem this
is a story of
of of
i'm sorry i'm just overwhelmed right now
um
look
i'm
i'm gonna get myself together and i'll
thank everyone proper when i get off
stage but on behalf of hulu and
searchlight and onyx the beautiful women
of hanukks and
and uh
concordia and and play action and vulcan
and radical media and
on behalf of joseph and and
i'm so happy right now i could cry
thank you
you